大家好，欢迎各位。大家今天怎么样？这将是一堂
非常棒的听说课。我很高兴大家都能来。欢迎
各位。看到屏幕了吗？好的。现在呢？是的。好的。那么记住，良好
的沟通始于良好的倾听，做一个积极的倾听者意味着展现出
你的专注。有时我们为了抓住大意会快速倾听，那是我们
快速而直觉的思维方式；而另一些时候，我们需要仔细的、分析性的
倾听，那才是我们真正深入剖析事物并试图
理解其深层含义的时候。所以我们需要练习这两种倾听方式，
以便理解事物的表层含义
和理解事物更深层次的分析性层面。当你练习多了，
你就会掌握窍门，不必刻意去
努力理解那么多。你会自然而然地理解，并且随着时间的推移会变得更直观。但是
先进行分析总是好的。那么，我们来听一下这里朗读的场景。
我希望你们带着不同的侧重点听两遍，我试图展示一些
你们可能不理解的东西。所以如果没听懂也不要难过。好的。
好的。好的，各位同事。关于新项目，我需要每个人在周二下班前 (COB)
协同整合各自的交付成果，并确保积极主动地与利益相关者沟通。
请迅速处理。你理解了吗？大意明白了，但是有一些新词。
其他的还可以。好的，所以你有一些经验，这很好。你抓住了
我们需要共同努力完成某事的大意，但这里可能有一些
你不理解的地方。哪些词你觉得难以理解？
所以我不理解的词是
"synergize" 和 "snappy"。好的，那么 "synergize" 某事物基本上就是让事物
同步，对吧？当事物同步时，它们就是 "synergized"（协同的）。它们
能很好地协同工作、配合默契，对吧？所以我们需要每个人基本上都团结起来，
就交付成果——即周二前需要产出的东西——达成一致，而 "make it snappy"
就是快速完成。哦，好的。当你在说话的时候，
你用那个词，对吧？哦，“动作快点”(make it snappy)。
好的。那么，让我们听一个简短的场景，想象你正在参加
这个会议。如果你在会议中听到那样的话，你会怎么做
来打断并试图理解？如果你有某种问题，你理解了大意，对吧？
但你可能还是想听听接下来会说些什么。
你会如何请求澄清呢？
嗯，正如您所说，一切都关乎倾听。所以我想我会等那个人
说完他（要说的话）？如果我不明白，那么我会去
说，嘿，关于我刚才说的这部分，我需要澄清一下。
所以你会等那个人说完他想说的话。*这是因为
你不想在别人说话时显得无礼或打断他们。是的。实际上，我总是
尽量等待，因为你需要知道对方在想什么，而
不是只从字面意思去理解你所说的话。是的，不做假设是好的。我同意。而且等待
谈话和对话中的那些停顿，以便知道何时可以请求澄清，这很好。
好的。那么我们如何礼貌地打断呢？这是我们今天讨论内容的一部分。
请求澄清。有一些有用的短语。嗯，我会说，打扰一下，
比如，那会是一个很好的例子。
所以我会说，打扰一下，我只是想知道当您谈论
这份合同时，您想表达的是什么，或者类似这样的话。好的。所以我需要关于这些主题的更多澄清。
好的。非常正式。我喜欢这样。
是的，我们需要……那就像我们开会时交谈的环境。
我们可以在外面开玩笑，你知道，但是当我们在开会时，我们需要努力做到
非常专业。你可以在会议之外更随意一些，但在会议
本身，就应该表现得专业和正式。好的。所以这种语言风格确实
有点正式，而且语调也很重要。你知道，声音有起有落。所以
一个例子是，抱歉，您能重复一下关于 COB 的部分吗？或者，您能重复一下关于
“动作快点”(making it snappy) 的部分吗？那是什么意思？好的。现在注意我们这里用了 "could"，而 "could"
被认为比 "can" 更礼貌。所以 "could" 更正式一点，而 "can" 则
更随意一点，尽管两者都可以使用。如果有人用 "can"，并不代表他不尊重，
但如果你想表现得更正式，最好用 "could"。这里有另一个例子。
这次我希望你试着在结尾提高语调。比如，“是这样吗？”(Is that right?)
好的。“是这样吗？”你能，你能读一下这部分吗？
如果我理解正确的话，您是要求我们……，是这样吗？
是这样吗？是的。这里还有另一个例子。我们工作很努力。是这样吗？
我们这个周末必须来。是这样吗？好的。这个怎么样？你能为我们读一下
这个吗？您能解释一下您说的 "snappy" 是什么意思吗？
嗯哼。非常好。嗨，"snappy"。嗯，"snappy" 的意思是动作敏捷/干脆利落。
嗯，不，我觉得那样可以。我们可以用，例如，像您说的 COB，因为
有些人不知道 COB 是什么意思。你可以简单地问，您能告诉我
"snappy" 是什么意思吗？我不认识这个词。这对我来说是个新词，你可以这么说。
你知道，我想有时候当我们不知道某件事时，会感到尴尬。
所以我们不想问，不想承认，但是请求澄清是可以的。
沟通和商业的全部目的就是理解和被理解。
这张幻灯片的一个关键点基本上是，我们用 "could" 来提出礼貌的请求。
你可以使用像 "Excuse me" 或 "If I understand correctly, you're asking..." 或 "you're telling us that's right" 这样的话语标记，
然后重述他们所说的话。这些都是非常好的方式
来请求澄清。好的。那么，请继续，抱歉。
不，也许以前我不会那样做，但现在我感觉更有信心去询问词语的意思，
去了解他们在说什么。所以我们知道他们到底想表达什么。
是的……只会随着时间的推移越来越好。